well hey there thank you for being here
especially if this is your first time
with us Adventist or otherwise tonight
we're going to be taking a look at a
part of a presentation from SDA Pastor
Dwayne lemon which was titled what is
the gospel it provides us with a perfect
example of how the Adventist Church's
extra biblical worldview the great
controversy theme it distorts all of
scripture leading to errant conclusions
even on subjects as vital as the gospel
so the question of tonight how is a
person made right with God and that
really is at the heart of the Gospel
message it is how a sinner can be made
right with God and it's been one of my
central contentions regarding Adventist
theology that the way adventism teaches
you can be made right with God is Not
only incorrect but it will not bring you
peace with God before we start I want to
remind everyone of an explanation of the
great controversy worldview from SDA
Theologian Herbert Douglas which was
published in the December 2000 issue of
ministry magazine for 7th Day Adventist
the great controversy theme is the core
concept that brings coherence to all
biblical subjects every philosophical or
theological system Builds on a central
governing theme or Paradigm its central
theme becomes the system's core truth
and determines all of that system's
principles and policies step Hawking the
remarkable Cambridge physicist wrote in
his 1988 book A Brief History of Time
that should scientists discover the long
sought Theory of Everything to explain
the varying mechanisms of the universe
we should know the mind of God 7th Day
Adventists have been given that a
perspective which provides a theory of
everything it introduces us to the mind
of God we didn't Discover it it was
given to us we call it the great
controversy theme how we understand this
Core theme directly affects how we grasp
the intent of the biblical writers when
they used words such as righteousness
salvation gospel Etc the great
controversy theme helps us to work our
way through S CES of theological
confusion over the meaning of such
realities as justification
sanctification atonement obedience and
works without the great controversy
theme all would remain divided over such
subjects as the importance of the Old
Testament Sanctuary service and the New
Testament view of Christ as our high
priest mediator the meaning of faith and
Grace the place of obedience in relation
to legalism why Jesus came the first
time why he came the way he did and when
will return this is to say that the
great controversy theme did not come
from the Bible as Douglas notes it was
allegedly given to the SDA church not
discovered it is the equivalent of
having access to the mind of God and the
theory of everything and how they
understand this theme directly affects
how they grasp what the Bible means with
such words as righteousness salvation
and gospel this means that the SDA
church has their own novel message about
how you can be made right with God and
since the apostle OST didn't have a
great controversy worldview and it's
doing the defining of what the apostles
meant this must mean that the SDA church
has a different gospel than what the
apostles preached something that Paul
tells us in Galatians 1 is cursed by God
and people are warned to flee from such
with that in mind we're going to listen
to some of SDA Pastor Dwayne lemon and
see how Downstream of this worldview is
the practical application and teaching
of it to Adventist leoty leading them
astray while using the Bible to do such
make sure to keep in mind what we were
just told by Herbert
Douglas it says in Isaiah 42 and: 21 or
when you get there please say Amen the
Bible says in 42 in verse Isaiah 42:21
the Lord is well pleased for his
righteousness sake he will magnify the
law and make it
honorable he will magnify the law and
make it honorable how did Jesus do this
you see when man fell into sin did you
know one did you know that Satan's Chief
argument was that God was too
exacting when man fell into sin Satan
began to put out the accusation that God
is too exacting he he was unjust and
unfair because how can he have such a
holy and righteous law and expect man to
live up to this law how could God do
that so he became a mass accuser not
just of the Brethren but of God himself
there's no way that any body could live
in total obedience to a law that was so
holy and so high that it was impossible
to keep and do you know my brothers and
sisters that that's one of the key
reasons why Jesus when he came to Earth
he had to come with a sinful nature so
right off the bat we hear the great
controversy narrative being read into
the Bible because nowhere does Scripture
say what Dwayne lemon claimed what he
cited in Isaiah doesn't say that Jesus
came to Earth to silence accusations
made by Satan and this is what would
magnify the law and silence the devil he
is reading into the phrase to magnify
his law his extra biblical Concepts and
ideas coming from Ellen White in the
great controversy worldview remember
what Herbert Douglas told us the great
controversy theme does it defines all
things in Adventist theology including
why the Adventist Jesus came Christ left
his position in the Heavenly courts and
came to this earth to live the life of
human beings this sacrifice he made in
order to show that Satan's charge
against God is false that it is possible
for man to obey the laws of God's
kingdom which is exactly what Dwayne is
getting at but this isn't what the Bible
teaches about why Jesus incarnated again
in Patriarchs and Prophets a book she
claimed was barricaded by a thus sayeth
the Lord she writes from the first the
great controversy had been upon the law
of God Satan had sought to prove that
God was unjust and that his law was
faulty and that the good of the universe
required it to be changed in attacking
the law he aimed to overthrow the the
authority of its author in the
controversy it was to be shown whether
the Divine statutes were defective and
subject to change or perfect and
immutable once again though nowhere does
the Bible say this by the first of the
great controversy she's referring to
prior to Earth's Creation in this
narrative the Earth was created after
the start of this supposed controversy
between Jesus and Satan which is to say
that prior to the Earth even existing
Satan began making these accusations
that Dwayne lemon is talking about
but nowhere does the bible teach that
Satan began attacking the Ten
Commandments claiming the things that Mr
Lemon and Ellen White claim let alone
that this happened and started before
the creation of the Earth the adven
system reads into the title of Satan
being the accuser to then claim that
includes an accuser in the ways Ellen
White has put forth in this narrative
with certain specificity that's not
found in the Bible and what this shows
is how this cannot be separated from
Adventist teaching this extra biblical
information is what informs what the SDA
Church teaches about how you can be made
right with God which is what the good
news of the Gospel really centers on the
person and work of Jesus Christ who he
is and what he came to do the great
controversy worldview informs that for
the Adventist system and it's why they
have a false gospel but then he said
this is why Jesus had to come with a
sinful nature this might be one of the
SDA Church's most internally
controversial doctrines modernists hate
it but classicists like Dwayne lemon
understand its vital importance to the
overall framework and the support
documentation is on his side because
this is what the official publishing
arms and Ellen White herself have stated
repeatedly think of Christ's humiliation
he took upon himself Fallen suffering
human nature degraded and defiled by sin
he took our sorrows bearing our grief
and shame he endured all the Temptations
wherewith man is beset he United
Humanity with divinity a Divine spirit
dwelt in a temple of Flesh he United
himself with the temple the word was
made flesh and dwelt among us because by
doing so he could associate with the
sinful Sorrowing Sons and Daughters of
Adam so very clearly she states that
upon incarnating the ainst Jesus assumed
a human nature that was defiled by sin
however the common defense to these
claims and the clarifier can be found in
SDA historian George Knight's book
search for identity where he writes
Ellen White would set forth the second
track on the human nature of Christ
during the 1890s and the early years of
the 20th century her position had
important similarities and sign ific
theological differences from that of
Jones Wagner and Prescott it was similar
in that she also claimed that Christ
took upon him our sinful nature that he
took upon himself Fallen suffering human
nature degraded and defiled by sin and
that he assumed our fallen human nature
thus we cannot have the slightest doubt
that Ellen White agreed with the 1888
reformers to the extent that Christ
accepted Fallen sinful human nature at
the Incarnation on the other hand she
diametrically opposed their theology
that he was just like every other child
of Adam without a particle of difference
between him and us this is to say they
assert that Jesus had a fallen sinful
human nature but no sinful inclinations
to act upon he essentially incarnated in
flesh that had 4,000 or so years of wear
and tear on it from the fall of Adam but
since he never acted upon his sinful
nature and had no desire to sin they'll
say he wasn't a sinner in conjunction
with this they'll typically cite Romans
8 and say that Paul says Jesus came in
the likeness of sin flesh which is
supposed to mean that he had a sinful
nature but this is absolutely heretical
for starters scripture teaches that we
are made in the likeness and image of
God does this therefore mean that
everything God is we are too if not then
that proves that being made in the
likeness of something doesn't
automatically mean that you share
everything as a one toone and this is
precisely what Paul is getting at
contextually he tells us that Jesus came
in the likeness of sinful flesh because
the human body that he assumed had the
appearance of being sinful due to its
sustaining the punishment for our sins
as the same Paul tells us in 2
Corinthians 5 that he who knew no sin
became sin so that we might become the
righteousness of God this is in
reference to the point at which our sins
were placed on Christ on the cross not
in his act of incarnation by taking on a
sinful nature furthermore this verse in
Romans 8 is after Paul has already
compared and contrasted the First adom
with the second adom back in chapter 5
and chapter 8 must be understood in
light of this therefore just as Sin came
into the world through one man and death
through sin and so death spread to all
men because all sinned for sin indeed
was in the world before the law was
given but sin is not counted where there
is no law yet death reigned from Adam to
Moses even over those whose sinning was
not like the transgression of Adam who
was a type of the one who was to come
but the free gift is not like the
trespass for if many died through one
man 's trespass much more have the grace
of God and the free gift by the grace of
that one man Jesus Christ abounded for
many and the free gift is not like the
result of the one man's sin for the
Judgment following one trespass brought
condemnation but the free gift following
many trespasses brought justification
for if because of one man's trespass
death reigned through that one man much
more will those who receive the
abundance of grace and the free gift of
righteousness reign in life through the
one man Jesus Christ so here we get a
compare and contrast between the first
and second Adam one man's trespass led
to death spreading to all of Adam's
Fallen posterity but Jesus did not die
because of that same reason because he
was not in the line of Fallen Adam
that's why we die but the second Adam
died at the hands of Sinners to
ultimately bring about the
reconciliation of Sinners to God which
is something Jesus freely chose to do
this is to say that the second Adam is
not in the Fallen line of the first
first Adam he is a new man Romans 5:14
told us that the first Adam was only a
type of one who was to come which
further proves that Jesus did not have a
fallen sinful flesh like all of Adam's
posterity do it also proves that Romans
8 is not saying that Jesus had a sinful
nature but that Christ came in true
likeness of humanity and bore the
iniquities placed upon him at Calvary
and the second Adam Jesus was not born
dead in sins and trespasses like the
rest of humanity is according to
Ephesians 2 and Colossians 2 but this is
necessary in the Adventist framework the
claim is that Satan made these
accusations that the Ten Commandments
are unfair and can't be kept so Jesus
had to come in sinful flesh to
demonstrate to Fallen Sinners that this
is false silent Satan's accusations and
vindicate God from all these accusations
before the entire watching Universe
which is what's at the heart of the
Seventh Adventist system of theology
another unbiblical concept foreign to
the Bible God will test all even as he
tested Adam and Eve to see whether they
will be obedient our loyalty or
disloyalty will determine our Destiny
since the fall of Adam men in every age
have excused themselves for sinning
charging god with their sin saying that
they could not keep his Commandments
this is the insinuation Satan cast at
God in heaven but the plea I cannot keep
the Commandments need never be presented
to God for before him stands the Savior
the marks of the crucifixion upon his
body a living witness that the law can
be kept it is not that men cannot keep
the law but that they will not this is
to say that the Adventist Jesus came to
show you that you can keep the law as
perfectly as he did and you must do so
to inherit eternal life by demonstrating
that you are fit for heaven and if
you're asking how perfect is perfect in
the same publication from the SDA church
we read and Enoch walked with God and he
was not for God took him Genesis 5:24 it
is only a short Journey to the Heavenly
Hills Brethren if we walk with God in
John 15:10 Jesus tells us that he kept
his father's Commandments he did not say
I am trying to keep them but he says I
have kept them so it is not enough that
we try to keep the Commandments we must
keep them the character of the Saints is
not established by their failures to
keep the commands of God but by their
success in doing so those who simply try
to keep the Commandments are moral
cripples they do not walk with God they
simply hobble along after him so catch
that trying your best is not what
vindicates God in this model trying your
best is not enough in the model if sin
is transgression of the law and we're
being told one must keep the law
perfectly as perfect as Jesus did trying
your best is not enough then this
article is advocating for sinless
perfectionism you must be as perfect as
Jesus was to inherit eternal life but
none of this is biblical that isn't the
good news about how you can be made
right with God don't get me wrong there
is coming a day where a person will be
totally freed from sin but this teaching
as we're going to see in a little bit
puts the cart before the horse it is all
predicated upon an extra biblical
worldview that is brought to the Bible
where various one-off statements are
read like Isaiah 42:21 and then
heretical concepts are read into the
text he had to take on the Fallen nature
of man because Jesus had to prove Satan
wrong on every level he came to
vindicate his father and say no my
father did not give any law that was too
hard to keep because notice what the
Bible says Jesus was able to do what
you're about to read what I'm about to
show you is a commentary on the entire
life of Jesus Christ of which no other
human being could honestly say until
Jesus Christ go to John 15 when you look
at John 15 what Jesus says right here
there was no other human being that
could honestly and sincerely say this
verse notice what it says John we're
looking at the 15th chapter and in John
15 notice what the Bible says as we
consider John 15 and verse 10 the Bible
says in John 15 and verse 10 it says if
ye keep my Commandments ye shall abide
in my love now watch what Jesus says
next even as I have what he says even as
I have kept my father's Commandments and
abide in his love do you know Christ is
the only one that could make that
statement from the Cradle to the Grave
Jesus was the only person that kept his
father's Commandments all the way
through and at no point did he fail and
so the cross was so powerful because it
destroyed the very argument of Satan it
destroyed it when Satan was saying God's
law is too holy and too high for man to
keep Jesus says I'll prove you
differently that's the reason why when
Jesus walked on this Earth he would not
do
anything that would represent his
natural
deity ah so here we hear Mr Lemon
reiterating the same line of reasoning
that we heard from the December 10 1889
issue of the review in Herald utilizing
the exact same verse which the
organization used to say trying your
best is not good enough only total
Perfection now maybe Mr Lemon is happy
to go on record for us stating that he
has achieved glorification and no longer
fall short of the glory of God because
that's exactly what he is preaching and
unless he is totally sinless then
according to his own organization's
Source documents he isn't actually
following God he's just a moral
that's only hobbling along after him but
once again we hear more great
controversy narrative being mingled in
with the biblical text John 15 has
nothing to do with the pre-earth
accusations made by Satan regarding the
Ten Commandments not being fair you
won't find this anywhere in scripture
and had Dwayne actually walked through
John 15 verse by verse instead of
cherry-picking things out to try and
hitch the great controversy wagon to he
wouldn't have been able to abuse the
Bible in this fashion John 15 1-11 is an
example that Jesus gives us of the
Covenant people of God he says I am the
True Vine and my father is the vine
dresser every branch in me that does not
bear fruit he takes away and every
branch that does bear fruit he prunes
that it may bear more fruit already you
were clean because of the word that I
have spoken to you abide in me and I in
you as the branch cannot bear fruit by
by itself unless it abides in the vine
neither can you unless you abide in me I
am the vine you are the branches whoever
abides in me and I in him he it is that
bears much fruit for apart from me you
can do nothing if anyone does not abide
in me he is thrown away like a branch
and Withers and the branches are
gathered thrown into the fire and burned
if you abide in me and my words abide in
you ask whatever you wish and it will be
done for you by this my father is
glorified that you bear much fruit and
so proed to be my disciples as the
father has loved me so have I loved you
abide in my love if you keep my
Commandments you will abide in my love
just as I have kept my father's
Commandments and abide in his love these
things I have spoken to you that my joy
may be in you and that your joy may be
full this is simply another picture of
the wheat and the tears both growing in
the same field the living branches and
dead branches are both attached to the
same thing with the true born- again
believer being in Union with Christ and
bearing fruit not not simply just
professing to be a Christian but they
have fruit to support it unlike the dead
branches who merely make a confession
but have no fruit and these false
converts that are tears will eventually
be cut off from the tree and thrown into
the fire when Jesus returns to separate
the wheat from the chaff so the review
and Herald and Dwayne lemon read into
this that bearing fruit is the
equivalent of sinless perfectionism with
word association fallacy being utilized
with the word Commandments in verse 10
to claim Jesus was referring to The Ten
Commandments exclusively except in verse
12 where Jesus goes on to explain what
Commandments mean in this context this
is my commandment that you love one
another as I have loved you greater love
has no one than this that someone lay
down his life for his friends you are my
friends if you do what I command you so
Jesus is teaching the disciples in this
chapter they are concerned about his
soon physical departure back to the
father and within this he explains to
them that they will bear much fruit as
his disciples if they love one another
and do as he has told them to do through
throughout his ministry as the
foundation layers of the church the
world would know that they are his
disciples in his physical absence by
their love for each other in a hostile
world to Jesus and his gospel that's the
Commandment in focus to read into this
that until you attain to sinless
perfectionism you aren't following God
and are a moral is not only a
horrible handling of the text but it's a
false understanding of how a person can
be made right with God something we will
look at a little bit later under ging
all of this is the SDA teaching that the
Adventist Jesus came as are great
example I used to hear the term used he
was the wayshower what was historically
called Model man theology in their
system it's another one of these areas
that takes General truths like that
Christians should follow Jesus but then
inserts into that that that means that
you are as sinless as he is despite the
fact that as Mr Lemon himself recognized
Jesus didn't sin one single time as
Ellen White writes in Desire of Ages
another book that she claimed was
barricaded by a thus sayeth the Lord of
the bitterness that falls to the law of
Humanity there was no part which Christ
did not taste there were those who tried
to cast contempt upon him because of his
birth and even in his childhood he had
to meet their scornful looks and evil
whisperings if he had responded by an
impatient word or look if he had
conceited to his brothers by even one
wrong act he would have failed of being
a perfect example thus he would have
failed of carrying out the plan for our
Redemption had he even admitted that
there could be an excuse for sin Satan
would have triumphed and the world would
have been lost this is why the tempter
worked to make his life as trying as
possible that he might be led to sin so
is that why Satan was trying to cause
Jesus to sin because it would have
Vindicated his pre-earth accusations
about the Ten
Commandments remember what Herbert
Douglas told us the great controversy
theme informs what the Bible supposedly
teaches about why Jesus incarnated it
wasn't just to silence accusations made
by Satan and vindicate the law but also
to be the perfect example of what you
must do if you want to be saved saved
following Jesus is equated with getting
to a point of keeping the law perfectly
as perfect as Jesus did this is how one
is ultimately seen as righteous safe to
save and made right with God but this
shows a fundamental lack of
understanding around righteousness and
how one can be seen as righteous in
God's sight as Paul writes in Romans 3
but now the righteousness of God has
been manifested apart from the law
although the law and the prophets bear
witness to it the righteousness of God
through faith in Jesus Christ for all
who believe for there is no distinction
for all of and fall short of the glory
of God and are justified by his grace as
a gift through the Redemption that is in
Christ Jesus whom God put forward as a
propitiation by his blood to be received
by faith this was to show God's
righteousness because in his Divine
forbearance he had passed over former
sins it was to show his righteousness at
the present time so that he might be
just and the justifier of the one who
has faith in Jesus the righteousness
that the believer can have comes apart
from the law it comes through faith
alone in Jesus Christ Alone and it was
the putting forth of Christ as a
propitiatory sacrifice that demonstrated
God's righteousness which would mean
that God is Not on trial and needing to
be Vindicated he very clearly
demonstrated that he is who he says he
is in the person of Jesus Christ and at
Calvary but in the great controversy
model righteousness does come from the
law one must have faith in the Adventist
Jesus who will now Empower you to keep
the law perfectly making up where you
fall short with his own Divine Merit as
you were on the pathway to Total
sinlessness something that must be
achieved before the close of probation
which is another great controversy
deception Ellen White writes when it is
in the heart to obey God when efforts
are put forth to this end Jesus accepts
this disposition and effort as man's
best service and he makes up for the
deficiency with his own Divine Merit so
you could think of the Adventist model
of how to be made right with God looking
something like this the beginning bar is
the brand new Adventist who has come to
the Adventist Jesus they now are
empowered to start keeping the law
because if they truly came to the
Adventist Jesus they will have new
desires to do such but this won't happen
immediately overnight because
sanctification is a process
sanctification in their model being
empowered to more and more keep the law
along the way when you fall short you
and your best efforts are accepted and
Jesus makes up for the difference with
his own Divine merits making it a
Cooperative effort on the pathway to
Total sinlessness which you'll see on
the right must be achieved before the
close of Probation and Jesus ceases
being a mediator it is only people that
achieve this that will be found worthy
of eternal life made right with God and
vindicate God but is that how a person's
made right with God through trying
really really hard to do your best to
keep the law Jesus assisting you along
the way imparting to you his Divine
merits resulting in you eventually
keeping the law perfectly as he did
silencing Satan yourself and vindicating
God in the great controversy
demonstrating that you're safe to save
and you won't let sin enter Heaven
Again of course not because all of this
is defined by an extra biblical
worldview that reads all sorts of
Concepts and ideas into the Bible that
are not there so I want to close by
looking at a number of important
doctrines and issues around the subject
that will hopefully clear the fog first
we will look at positional versus
experiential sanctification then we will
look at what the Bible says about the
sinful nature of man a little bit
followed by what it says regarding
glorification and more specifically we
will see that there is a specific order
to all of this and see how the SDA
framework short circuits this by placing
an undue burden upon people that they
cannot possibly bear not only that but
it will lead their soul to predition
because believing this message that they
preach will not bring you peace with God
one such example of positional and
experiential sanctification being found
in scripture is found in Hebrews 10
where we
read when he said above you have neither
desired nor taken pleasure in sacrifices
and offerings and burnt offerings and
sin offerings these are offered
according to the law then he added
behold I have come to do your will he
does away with the first in order to
establish the second and by that will we
have been Sanctified through the
offering of the body of Jesus Christ
once for all and every priest stands
daily at his service offering repeatedly
the same sacrifices which can never take
away sins but when Christ had offered
for all time a single sacrifice for sins
he sat down at the right hand of God
waiting from that time until his enemy
should be made a foot stol for his feet
for by a single offering he has
perfected for all time those who are
being Sanctified so this part of the
passage is the author's closing thoughts
on the superiority of Jesus's priesthood
before transitioning to the hall of
faith in the next chapter in verse 10
tells us that by the single once for all
time sacrifice of Christ the believer
has been Sanctified past tense as John
Gil notes in his Hebrews commentary that
is by the sacrifice of Christ which was
willingly offered up by himself and was
according to the will of God it was his
will of purpose that Christ should be
crucified and slain and it was his will
of command that he should lay down his
life for his people and it was grateful
and well pleasing to him that his soul
should be made an offering for sin and
that for this reason because hereby the
people of God are Sanctified their sins
are perfectly expiated the full pardon
of them is procured their persons are
completely Justified from sin and their
consequences purging from it even though
the offering of the body of Jesus Christ
once for all this is said not to the
exclusion of his soul it designs his
whole human nature and that as in Union
with his Divine person and is
particularly mentioned in illusion to
the legal sacrifices the bodies of slain
beasts which are types of him and with
reference to his father's preparation of
a body for him for this purpose Hebrews
10:5 so Gil rightly points out that the
sacrifice of Christ accomplished the
total sanctification of the believer in
full already he perfectly expiated and
procured the complete justification
sanctification and glorification of the
believer and this is a present reality
for the believer who is in Christ Jesus
right now they are already seen as
completely Holy by virtue of being in
Christ this is to say their positional
sanctification before God is already
complete and full due to being totally
justified pardoned and holy before God
on account of Jesus Christ but back in
Hebrews 10 we also read in verse 14 that
by the perfect sacrifice of Christ the
believer is being Sanctified present
active tense not past tense and this is
where experiential sanctification comes
into play after coming to Christ a
person will begin to be made more and
more like God this process will take
place over the entire course of the
believer's life as the old old sinful
nature of man is more and more put to
death so the SDA system conflates
experiential and positional
sanctification by making experiential
sanctification the barometer for if a
person will be saved meaning if you
don't experience total sinlessness in
this life and Achieve that before
probation closes then you weren't
Sanctified to Total sinless Perfection
and you won't be worthy of eternal life
and this belief is Downstream of the SDA
Church's conflation between
justification and sanctification the
same issue that the Protestant
information sought to address coming out
of the medieval church when one
understands that positionally before God
on account of Christ a Believer is
already accepted adopted and completely
forgiven it is at that point that a
person will truly find Peace and Freedom
that only the gospel can give but this
leads us to the next point the sinful
nature of man the reason that total
sinlessness will not be achieved on this
side of Eternity is because sin is more
than just character blots and stains
such an example of this can be found in
Ellen White's test for the church Volume
5 where she writes not one of us will
ever receive the Seal of God while our
characters have one spot or stain upon
them it is left with us to remedy the
defects in our characters to cleanse the
sole Temple of every defilement then the
latter rign will fall upon us as the
early Reign fell upon the disciples on
the day of Pentecost perfectly in line
with their teaching regarding sinless
perfectionism as well as sanctification
if one can get their character
completely free from a single stain or
blot they will in essence be free from
sin in this model but the problem is
that sin is more than just stains or
blots upon the character while it is
true that certain actions and behaviors
are indeed sinful these are fruits of a
sinful root they are not the root itself
it's why a person needs to be born again
and they need to be glorified the act of
regeneration takes the spiritually dead
sinner who was born dead in sins and
trespasses and it raises that dead
Spirit to newness of life but as Paul
points out in Romans 7 this new man
begins Waring with the old man the old
sinful flesh will rear its head because
unlike the spirit it hasn't had its
change made yet this change will come
when glorification is applied and this
Segways us into the final and third
point in his book Redemption
accomplished and applied Theologian John
Murray gives a very succinct definition
of what the Bible teaches about
glorification he writes glorification is
the final phase of the application of
redemption it is that which brings to
completion the process which begins in
effectual calling indeed it is the
completion of the whole process of
redemption for glorification means the
attainment of the goal to which the
elect of God were predestined in the
Eternal purpose of the father and it
involves the consummation of the
Redemption secured and procured by the
vicarious work of Christ so
glorification is the final benefit that
Christ procured for believers finally
being applied at the final moments
before being united with our maker face
to face and Paul gives us some details
about this application of glorification
in 1 Corinthians
15 he writes I tell you this Brothers
flesh and blood cannot inherit the
kingdom of God nor does the perishable
inherit the imperishable behold I tell
you a mystery we shall not all sleep but
we shall all be changed in a moment in
the twinkling of an eye at the last
trumpet for the trumpet will sound and
the dead will be raised imperishable and
we shall be changed for this perishable
body must put on the imperishable and
this Mortal body must put on immortality
when the perishable puts on the
imperishable and the Mortal puts on
immortality then shall come to pass the
saying that is written death is
swallowed up in Victory oh death where
is your Victory oh death where is your
sting now he told us back in verse 42
that what is sown will be raised this
body of death that we possess will be
swn into the ground to then be raised
with immortality the corruptible sinful
flesh will be changed in the twinkling
of an eye when glorification is applied
at the resurrection until glorification
is applied a person will war with sin
and possess a sinful flesh that cannot
inherit the kingdom of God the root of
being a sinner is the actual nature we
possess as Fallen Sons and Daughters of
Adam until that is changed a person will
war and struggle with sin one cannot
Short Circuit the process of arriving at
glorification before the resurrection
when God has determined that he will
apply that benefit that Christ obtained
for believers at Calvary once the root
changes then the war with sin will be
over and the fruit will be totally
perfect but Ellen White claim CL that
this is not the case in Sons and
Daughters she writes we are not to
settle down expecting that a change of
character will come to us by some
miraculous work when Jesus shall appear
in the Clouds Of Heaven with power and
great Glory no my young friends we are
judgment bound and probation is granted
to us here in this life in order that we
may form characters for the future
Immortal Life while it is true that True
Believers will not simply lay down in
the war with sin but will continue
fighting the good fight attached to this
truth she includes that there will be no
change in character when Jesus returns
sin being understood to be character
blots and that probation has been
granted to people with the express
purpose of allowing them the time to
achieve total sinlessness now again
evidencing the short circuiting of
Salvation namely the application of
glorification essentially putting forth
the idea that one can arrive at
glorification before the resurrection
not only can they but they must if they
want to be saved
what Dwayne lemon and the avenus system
are putting forth is Noble but it is a
crafty deception while it sounds Pious
and lofty it's not what the Bible
teaches about how you can be made right
with God and hopefully if you're a
Christian you are starting to see how
interconnected all of Sate theology is
such as probation and sinless
perfectionism being a part of the
Adventist gospel they are part of how
you can be made right with God God most
certainly changes people and one is not
the same after encountering the Risen
Christ but you aren't going to
shortcircuit the order by by which God
works and change your corruptible flesh
through trying really really hard and
that's the root issue the avenus system
binds people to trying to do something
that is impossible and then it tells
them that their spiritual eternity is
dependent upon achieving such and this
is a perfect example of how the great
controversy worldview takes General
truths and biblical phrases and defines
them in light of its extra biblical
Baseline narrative there is zero
biblical support for the belief that
before the creation of the Earth
Satan began accusing the Ten
Commandments of being unfair and we
didn't hear Mr Lemon explain what
exactly triggered this which is the
claim by Ellen White that Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with God the
father and it was that act that led
Lucifer to become jealous become Satan
the adversary and the accuser of the Ten
Commandments this is not only not
biblical but it's damnable heresy that
presents a god that is not the god of
the Bible and a narrative that doesn't
have its roots in the Bible but it is
brought to the text to try and find
things that can uphold it giving the
appearance of being biblical Adventists
can be made right with God in full today
secure in Jesus Christ who is a perfect
and Powerful savior the gospel really is
that simple Jesus Christ God in flesh
entered into his own creation he lived a
perfect and sinless life the life that
you and I have failed to live he died a
grueling and bloody death on a cross at
the hands of Sinners where the sins of
the world were placed on him at Calvary
he who knew no sin became sin so that we
might become the righteousness of God a
great Exchange took place he took my sin
such that I can receive his
righteousness like Paul tells us in
Philippians 3 not in little spurts
imparted over time based on your
cooperation but in full at the point of
justification which is why he was buried
in the Tomb and raised on the third day
for our justification he accomplished
this work in full and he now promises it
to all who come to him and that he will
not cast them out but will raise them up
on the last day it's strictly on the
basis of what Jesus Christ did and
accomplished that this is possible and
you can be seen as perfect by virtue of
Jesus Christ and his perfect sinless
life in your place the Holy Spirit Will
regenerate all that believe the gospel
transferring them from the kingdom of
darkness into the Kingdom of Light you
will be a citizen of Christ's Kingdom
where you are already accepted in full
as a son or daughter of God on account
of Christ the Holy Spirit Will begin the
process of sanctification in your life
despite your position before God already
being secure which is a testimony to the
believer in the world that Jesus Christ
is alive you will have good days and you
will have bad days but in both you can
be reminded of the gospel and that Jesus
is enough that despite not being perfect
Christ is so keep your eyes on him which
really kind of gets us into the
discussion of the Lord's supper and what
that's about along with the preaching of
the word and the administration of the
sacraments something we didn't really
talk about but it does play a major role
in experiential sanctification eternal
life is not for those found worthy but
for the Unworthy and it's why the Lord
taught us in the Lord's Prayer which
should be prayed daily that we are to
take the humble posture of asking
forgiveness for our sins the go gospel
has nothing to do with silencing Satan
or the SDA Church's pre-earth origin
story but nevertheless May Christ richly
bless you in the grace and peace won by
Christ and his vicarious death on the
cross for Sinners as always until next
time God
bless oh
apostate did he say
that come on man
[Music]